plastique quand nos déchets valent de
l'or un documentaire auquel vous pouvez
bien sûr réagir sur le hashtag docu
débat un documentaire que vous avez
réalisé karim amour jeunes merci d'être
là près de vous michèle rivasi députée
européenne bonjour d'europe écologie les
verts
en face de vous valérie langlois bonjour
vous êtes professeur d'université à
paris est créteil directeur adjointe de
l'institut de chimie et des matériaux de
paris est et enfin eric brac de la
perrière bienvenus vous êtes directeur
général d'eco-emballages
alors qu'harry maman jeanne vous êtes
journaliste scientifique
pourquoi avoir choisi le plastique et
combien de temps ça vous a pris cette
enquête
c'est une enquête qui s'appellerait
complexe c'est vrai que c'est complexe
donc déjà il a fallu se plonger dans ce
qu'était la matière plastique et tout de
suite on découvre qu'il ya pas un
plastique
il ya des plastiques ya à peu près 700
plastique différents donc en effet c'est
d'abord tout un travail de fond de
comprendre ce qu'est le plastique vous
allez sûrement nous l'expliqué plus
clairement
après pourquoi le plastique parce que le
plastique est clairement partout quand
je lis partout c'est vraiment pas du sol
au plafond mais presque dans
l'automobile les emballages évidemment
le téléphone en fait c'est une matière
qui est pratique légère malléable du
coup voilà il y en a vraiment attendre
les objets indispensables est
indispensable et voilà partout alors en
2016 en france les sacs plastiques
devrait être interdit mais vous en
faites pour être documentaire vous êtes
davantage penchés sur l'objectif
européen 0 plastique dans nos décharges
en 2020 pourquoi plutôt l'angle européen
que franco-français
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de faire les choses dans son
pays a soit aujourd'hui vraiment tout et
il faut dépasser les frontières même si
culturellement il ya des différences
entre les pays mais bon voilà on le
revend vision écologique qui a de
grosses grosses heures l'artiste mais
bon il faut quand même essayer d'avancer
ensemble prendre l'exemple sur les pays
qui fonctionne bien et voilà tirer vers
le haut ce qu'ils sont un petit peu à la
traîne
je dis pas que la france l'est
complètement on va dire qu'elle est un
peu enfin quand on regarde vos
militaires
on sent qu'elle est un petit peu en
retard elle a un petit port cet objectif
européen 0 plastique dans la décharge en
2020 il est réaliste ou pas michèle
rivasi et que je sais pas zéro
d'ailleurs c'est sur les sacs plastiques
unique
on passe à l'heure actuelle grosso modo
il à 180 par an il faut passer on a dit
à la moitié en 2019 et en 2020 on a dix
81%
bon c'est un rapport de force parce que
c'est vrai que les pays anglo saxons
sont allés beaucoup plus loin de nous
mais normalement on devrait plus avoir
de sa plastique à usage unique
c'est pas tous les sacs plastiques sauf
que il y a le diable est dans les
détails on dit ça pour les sacs visible
mais par contre on a alors là les
écologistes étaient fous furieux parce
que on perd mais hélas on va peut-être
en parler d'utiliser ce qu'on appelle
les sacs oxo biodégradables c'est à dire
qui se fragmente oui et on a des
microparticules de plastique on va
retrouver dans notre environnement
c'est à dire tout ce qui est visible va
disparaître d'ailleurs la corse avait
anticipé ça parce qu'il ya plus de sacs
plastiques encore les dents de surface
de vente + tout ça c'était très bien
donc maintenant ça va être les états
membres qui vont être obligés de le
faire mais par contre on aura encore
plein de paillettes de microparticules
donc ils seront à part et ça va pas se
voir et ça va être problématique
et ça l'est déjà d'ailleurs ses intérêts
dans nos assiettes exactement
une autre réaction sur cet objectif
eri bagdad ap rien oui l'objectif
européen en fait il est intéressant
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ils
travaillent à une maille très importante
de population et vous savez que pour
bien recyclés pour aller plus avant dans
le notamment dans les transformations
pourraient faire en sorte qu'ils aient
moins de perturbations et moins d'impact
sur l'environnement
il faut pouvoir avoir des décisions qui
englobe un grand nombre de personnes
d'accord c'est vrai que aujourd'hui plus
de sacs plastiques dans les décharges en
france et à peu près la moitié qui vont
dans les décharges et ça il faut tendre
à réduire effectivement la mise en
décharge car la maison des charges avec
perturbe l'environnement et surtout on
ne récupère pas ses matières et donc on
all et on ne s'en sert pas et ont bien
sûr on n'économise pas les ressources
naturelles donc vraiment la mise en
décharge et
chose qu'il est vraiment passé tous est
souhaitable et cette décision est
vraiment bien maintenant sur le
plastique le sujet très très important à
la fois au niveau français à la fois au
niveau européen nous etc emballages on a
fait une expérimentation pour voir
comment recycler plus les plastiques sur
6 % de la population française plus de 4
millions d'habitants et on a regardé
comment on arrivait à le faire ou on
n'arrivait pas à le faire
eh ben on s'aperçoit que ça peut marcher
aujourd'hui on a développé un projet qui
nous permettrait de recycler de doubler
le taux de recyclage des plastiques
on a à peu près 10 ans qui à l'échelle
industrielle une courte durée et ça
pourrait transformer les choses
aujourd'hui on est à 23 pour exalead
recyclé on va est en effet à y revenir
je voudrais juste trois chiffres qui
sont vraiment intéressants en 1950 au
niveau mondial 1,5 million de tonnes de
production de plastique dans la moitié
pour les emballages
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 350 millions
de tonnes et dans dix ans nous serons à
750 millions de tonnes taux de recyclage
mondiale 25 20 20 % à peu près donc on
voit bien que cette situation l anémie
je dirais quand on est en france on sait
que eco-emballages va y arriver
notamment avec les collectivités locales
et si je regarde ce que consomment les
consommateurs un petit peu partout dans
le monde en fait ils consomment à peu
près la même chose parce que il ya du
nomadisme parce que les gens qui l'ont
fait tous la même façon vous les pays
n'ont pas tous la même façon traiter
leurs déchets non ils n'ont pas la même
façon mais alors pourquoi nous on en en
recycle aujourd'hui que 23% pourquoi on
est à la traîne alors sur les bouteilles
et flacons ça marche plutôt bien on est
à 50 % de taux de recyclage dans toutes
les bouteilles flacons et c'est ça
marche bien maintenant sur les autres
plastiques je pense qu'il faut arriver à
avoir en france des systèmes un peu plus
cohérent en terme de population et on va
y revenir
magali langlois vous êtes scientifique
et la question du plastique vous
travaillé dessus depuis vingt ans la
france est ce que la france a mis un peu
de temps à se préoccuper de cette
question là du recyclage peut-être un
petit peu mais de plus en plus on voit
quand même que par la communication les
gens' je pense qu'à une éducation au
niveau des consommateurs des citoyens
que les citoyens que nous sommes et nous
trions quand même de plus en plus nos
déchets c'est vrai que tous les mets
pauline tous les matchs des matières
plastiques ne sont pas recyclables c'est
peut-être là qu'il faut mettre les
efforts à savoir que les flacons les
bouteilles effectivement sont
recyclables les pots de yaourts de les
stylos tout ça c'est pas encore recyclés
il faut peut-être
travailler là dessus pour améliorer ses
systèmes de collecte de tri et puis
ensuite de recyclage alors effectivement
quand on regarde votre documentaire car
emma on comprend que en france on a du
mal à accepter l'idée que les déchets
peuvent avoir une valeur ses premières
choses et puis ce qui est encore plus
difficile c'est d'apprendre à trier ses
déchets on réécoute un extrait du
documentaire on en parle tout bien
évidemment les sacs plastiques sont de
recyclables et aucun problème c'est en
général en plus des sacs à base de
matières qui sont des matières bien
connu et c'est le vrai problème des sacs
plastiques c'est pas la recyclabilité
c'est la collecte si on prend l'exemple
des podiums reste pareil claude yaourt
ça se met pas dans la peau verre
recyclable pourtant cédé à matière
plastique qu'on sait parfaitement
recyclé bon ça a été des choix un moment
donné la tendance aujourd'hui je serais
tentée dire c'est à dire mettons tous
les plastiques dans la même poubelle
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui
travaillent sur les nouvelles consignes
de tri et des expérimentations qui ont
été faites qui vont se mettre en oeuvre
au niveau national après il faut arriver
à avoir une communication qui soit la
plus claire possible la plus simple
possible car maman jeanne faisait rage
oui dans cet extrait on comprend qu'en
fait le cri à quel moment il faut qu'ils
aient lieu est-ce que c'est aux citoyens
de le faire et dans ses galons demande
quand même à toute une population de tri
exactement la même manière lb consignes
qui sont extrêmement variés il faut
aller chercher dans chaque emballage est
tout petit ou bien est-ce que c'est un
centre de tri qui va être moderne qui va
travailler vraiment là dessus en terme
de recherche
on récupère les plastiques etc au centre
de tri de faire ce tri là et de les
distribuer à la bonne usine à la bonne
filière alors comment commençons par le
début et rivages de la paire comment ça
se passe la collecte des déchets en
france alors la collecte des déchets en
france partent avec ce pass de la
manière suivante ya 70 % de la collecte
qui se fait en porte à porte et vous
avez un bas devant votre petite maison
devant votre appartement
enfin dans le hall de l'immeuble de
votre appartement ou bien tout
simplement
chez vous les deux autres 30% c'est de
l'apport volontaire c'est à dire que ça
se passe notamment dans l'est dans les
campagnes où vous amener en fait vos
recyclables un point qui est proche de
chez vous et qui permet d'accueillir
tous et recyclables le constat qu'on
fait après 20 ans d'expérience et
d'attention sur ce sujet là le porte à
porte aujourd'hui est très onéreux et en
fait ne génère pas la quantité souhaitée
pourquoi pas tout simplement parce que
parfois il ya des immeubles qui sont pas
équipés ou bien c'est au mont au
deuxième sous-sol mal éclairé ça sent
mauvais donc ça ne donne pas envie de
recycler partout en europe et notamment
dans les pays du sud qu on oppose
souvent aux pays du nord en termes
d'efficacité mais là il s'avère que
c'est faux né en espagne en italie au
portugal il ya des systèmes d'apport
volontaire au coin de la rue proche des
transports proches des lieux où on va
faire ses courses qui permettent d'avoir
finalement plus de performances on sort
le la poubelle de débats font des
immeubles et on la met devant chaque
chaque enfin au point de chaque russe
qui permet d'avoir un rappel à tiens ça
je dois leur cycle voilà donc le premier
sujet c'est la collecte aujourd'hui est
complètement je dirais stable donc ne
progresse plus parce que le système de
collecte n'est pas adaptée à la demande
des consommateurs
michèle rivasi fait d'accord oui parce
que c'est vraiment infernal vous habitez
un immeuble dans la conception du meuble
on n'a pas prévu le recyclage donc il ya
un problème de formation
si vous les dents mais moi je pourrais
revenir parce que sur la réduction est
ce que vous avez dit 350 millions de
tonnes par an de déchets produits et
notamment plastiques produits
oui c'est incroyable c'est une source
financière dengue fait l'argent on va
vous malgré le réveil mais parce que je
me dis que pour les gens nous
consommateurs si d'une part on réduisait
les déchets à la source
et puis surtout quand on regarde tous
ces plastiques
venez de le dire mais enfin c'est
incroyable oui tous ces plastiques
certains se recyclent à on peut recycler
les bouteilles et les flacons mais on
peut pas recycler des emballages
facilement non mais on vend balle un peu
mais c'était juste pour qu'on comprenne
parce que c'est un problème qui est
compliqué il va falloir que la france
progresse donc voilà le système de
collecte en fait il ya une seule société
en france ô eric brac de la perrière qui
collecte les déchets c'est un monopole
la compétence de la collecte des données
aux collectivités locales c'est donc les
municipalités qui collecte les déchets
d'accord qui finance cette activité qui
est déficitaire
parce que les collectivités locales
dépense beaucoup d'accords et on
s'aperçoit qu'elles dépensent beaucoup
et c'est de plus en plus cher alors que
finalement on pourrait optimiser cette
fameuse collègues donc nous
eco-emballages confessé que à chaque
fois qu'il ya un emballage qui est
produit qui emballe un produit il paye
son recyclage ils versent eco emballage
environ 1 centime d'euro pour une
bouteille d'eau par exemple et nous on
leur verse aux collectivités locales 96%
de l'argent que nous collectons et
reversés aux collectivités locales
et là on tombe sur une grande question
c'est se dire mais finalement est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas avoir des bonnes
pratiques qui soient transférés de
collectivités locales en collectivités
locales parce que à quelques kilomètres
près on a parfois des acteurs qui font
très bien les choses avec un nombre de
tonnes très important avec de la
communication qui va bien avec un
recyclage de proximité d'accord et puis
une autre collectivité qui se trouve en
panne complètement
et bien c'est vrai que ça se passe mieux
à la campagne qu'en ville ça se passe
bout alors c'est assez aussi c'est un
sujet paradoxal pourquoi parce qu'en
france on recycle moitié moins en ville
qu'à la campagne
alors que nous sommes nous sommes 85%
habiter en ville dont là on consomme le
plus on recycle - si je compare comme
tout à l'heure avec l'italie ou
l'espagne
on recycle deux fois plus en ville qu'à
la campagne là bas donc il ya un vrai
sujet vous l'avez dit madame vous êtes
totalement raison d'équipements urbains
pour simplifier le geste de tri
aujourd'hui on rénove et on construit
cinq cent mille appartements logements
par an enfin on espère le faire aucun de
ces appartements ne sont prévus et quand
n'ayant d'entrée je dirais une place
pour le tri dans l'appartement
pour faire la séparation très peu sont
prévues qu'on va venir au vide ordures
comme comme à l'époque sauf que ce sera
avec nous on espère bien peut-être des
choses c'est que souvent ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure on met tous les
recyclables dans le même bac pour moi je
suis totalement contre ce sujet là le
consommateur il ne doit pas se
débarrasser de son emballage
il doit faire le geste de tri si jamais
il mais d'un côté ce qui est papier
carton et lors que tes skis menace-t-il
à l'aja n'a rien de juste
oui ici mais le papier carton à côté ils
placent dit que de l'autre côté
saaf épargne énormément de coups et ça
développe la qualité des magouilles mais
cette demande aussi aux individus
voulaient réagir valérie langlois oui
c'est vrai que c'est demandé on demande
beaucoup aux amateurs c'est vrai que
c'est le mieux ce serait de trier
suivant les matières plastiques partout
dans le monde aspects comme ça et ça
marche bien voilà mais il faut savoir
aussi maintenant que les usines sont
équipés pour justement trier les
différents la matière plastique
on sait maintenant qu'on peut jeter à la
fois les bouteilles d'eau les bouchons
qui sont faits en deux matières
plastiques différentes et c'est possible
de les trier dans l'oil fois de tri mais
en même qu'on arrive à faire évoluer
justement les rumeurs voué à la roue
d'un point de vue politique
expliquez-moi pourquoi il ya autant de
diversité et vous qui avez le monopole
sur le recyclage pourquoi on vous entend
pas plus vis-à-vis des collectivités
n'avons aucun monopole sur rien aucun
monopole avait 40 d'une activité
d'études recyclant pas du tout le
recyclage ce sont les opérateurs de
déchets qu'ils font avec des contrats
passés avec les collectivités nous nous
faisons une chose c'est que nous
collectons et nous prenons en faites
attention ne faisons attention au fait
de financer l'ensemble de cette filière
cette filière est négative c'est-à-dire
qu'elle est elle est déficitaire qu'est
ce que font les entreprises de la grande
consommation
il paye ça va jusqu'à 3 ou 4 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires pour faire en sorte
que j'ai payé par le consommateur s'est
payé par le consommateur pour faire en
sorte qu'on augmente le recyclage et on
s'aperçoit de quoi que nous avons
augmenté nos paiements collectivités
locales de plus de 30%
y'a même pas 7 % de tonnes en plus qu'on
récupère dans les poubelles
donc le sujet n'est pas un sujet
d'argent le sujet sain sujet d'optimiser
localement chacune des organisations
pour faire mieux avec les eaux brillent
éthiquement abraham il y aurait
tellement notre façon de recycler vous
savez pas une possibilité de coordonner
toutes ces collectivités
comme le dit jacques collet dans les
buts un peu ça sera ça veut dire quoi ça
qu'est-ce qu'elle les collectivités en
fond cet argent là bas les collectivités
ne dépensent l'argent mais un système de
collecte pas dans le recyclage donc si
ça peut ça peut être fait dans le
recyclage mais y'a manière et manière
c'est à garlin bas on a fait des études
qui montrent notamment sur le recyclage
des plastiques globalement une recycle
une tonne de plastique à recycler de
manière optimisée en france ou à l'état
à l'étranger comme l'ont fait nos études
en france et à l'étranger
ça coûte entre 600 et 800 euros la tonne
quand nous avons fait cette étude ici
notamment avec l'ademe et d'autres
organisations
nous avons mesuré que parfois ça coûtait
600 euros la tonne et parfois ça coûte
3000 euros la tonne ça veut dire que le
système ne fonctionne pas bien ce que je
disais tout à l'heure et vous avez
raison madame il faut que les bonnes
pratiques d 1 ha et vers les zones et
aujourd'hui moi je milite pour faire en
sorte que nous puissions réduire les
coûts de ce qu'ils sont trop chers pour
mettre les collectivités sont totalement
isolés ces questions là il n'y a pas un
intergroupe quelque chose qui alors
elles se rassemblent à elles font
globalement un très bon travail mais
dans certains cas et notamment dans les
villes on s'aperçoit que les coûts
montent et que la collègue baisse c'est
exactement l'inversé qu'il faut faire
donc nous nous souhaitons une seule
chose c'est d'avoir en fait une
optimisation pour qu'ils aient plus
d'efficacité que l'argent que donne le
consommateur il soit bien employé
bon eh oui carrément mois sur l'idée de
condat tous les plastiques etc c'est un
centre de tri de windsor je sais pas
vous aviez l'air de dire ce n'était pas
forcément ils n'ont jamais les
plastiques d'un côté parce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure qui arrivait une
plusieurs résine donc on met tous les
plastiques dans dans un dans un bac tous
les papiers et les cartons dans l'autre
et les plastiques vont dans un centre de
tri qui a été conçu pour les plastiques
ou lorsque j'entends des centres de tri
qui traite c'est un peu comme si vous
disiez je vais mélanger de la pâtisserie
avec je dirais des légumes et faire
quelque chose de cohérent
en fait les plastiques doivent être
traités comme un ensemble avec une usine
spécialisée plastique prier oui mais on
retrouve chacun joué et les parigots le
soft centre de tri qu'on voit dans le
documentaire il est extrêmement moderne
avec la lentille optique stamm enfin
c'est pas c'est pas le cas de tous les
centres de tri en france il fait
complètement fi dès que vous
totalement raison la taxe que vous
récoltez c'est là dedans qu'il faut
aller mettre de l'argent dans
l'augmentation de sang bleu tribe de ce
type quel investissement la
modernisation d'un centre de tri la
modernisation des centres de tri dans
leur ensemble et je parle de chiffres de
l'ademe
c'est environ un milliard d'euros et
c'est très intéressant parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que la france qui a
aujourd'hui 240 centres de tri un centre
de tri pour 250 mille habitants les pays
européens ont en moyenne un centre de
tri pour un million d'habitants
donc il faut trouver cette cette
magnifique vous ouvrez et la nouvelle
loi sur les régions les 13 régions est
très intéressante de ce fait s'il
regarde ça que du côté des déchets parce
qu'elle permet de massifier en fait la
collecte avec un nombre d'habitants
suffisant et arriver à créer des centres
de tri qui soit vraiment optimum alors
je sais pas d'opposer les uns les autres
non je sais plus ce qu'on est en train
d'investir très fortement c'est de
décider en fait de la feuille de route
ensemble pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse rester sur des coûts relativement
bas et augmenter le recyclage
michèle rivasi michel une question vous
poser depuis le temps que j'entends
eco-emballages depuis le temps que je
vois que vous intervenez dans les
collectivités de tout ça pour parler
beaucoup mais pourquoi n'y a pas plus
d'harmonisation
pourquoi il n'ya pas plus d'incitation
sur les collectivités qui travaillent
bien pas etc emballages qu'harmoniser
collectivités non mais vous savez c'est
l'état que les abonnés c'est nous ne
sommes pas état nous sommes une
entreprise
wii wii fit environ oui mais justement
appartement vous financez vous avez un
rôle important d'harmonisation de ce qui
est bien par rapport à ce qui est mal et
vous pouvez très bien dire hé bé plus
s'est recyclé plus apporte de l'argent à
la collectivité est ce qu'on fait donc
je trouve qu'il ya un manque
d'harmonisation je suis d'accord avec
vous voyez on passe d'une déchetterie à
l'autre et ben y'a même pas on sait pas
où on met les choses
donc pourquoi vous ne jouez pas un rôle
vu votre position clé dans le système
pour dire voilà le plan de recyclage
qu'on vous propose
voilà le type de déchets tri qui
profèrent puisque les collectivités
elles sont parties prenantes mais je
trouve qu'il n'ya pas vraiment de de
coordination et vous avec l'historique
que vous avez parce que vous avez depuis
de l'est
nous aurons vos années où travailler là
dedans on ne sent pas sur le terrain et
moi j'étais adjointe à la ville de bâle
ans je me suis occupé des déchets mais
je vous assure que ont changé de
responsabilité si vous voulez sur une
collectivité on n'avait pas le même type
de moi j'adore moi je le dis on est où
là et imaginer les consommateurs ils
achètent des produits savent pas où le
mettre
donc avant on pouvait valérie langlois
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
question-là d'avoir sur le tri sur cette
idée de mettre les plastiques dans un
seul endroit
quelle est votre position vous en tant
que scientifique en tant que
scientifique je pense que sur le plan de
la chimie on maîtrise quand même bien
les façons dont on pourrait recycler les
matières plastiques
maintenant faut voir qu'un emballage ses
complexes si on fait par exemple une
bouteille de un peu particulière qui
doit être imperméable au gaz imperméable
aux uv on est obligé de faire du multi
couches
donc là on va mettre différents types de
polymères et lorsqu'on va recycler ne
sera pas facile effectivement de séparer
même là les différentes matières
plastiques et de refaire un objet avec
ce polymère beau avec cette matière
plastique donc là il ya vraiment des
recherches qui sont amenées pour
justement faire valoir aussi modifié la
fabrication de certaines choses oh je
sais pas s'il faut aller jusque là mais
au moins la façon séparée les années à
venir c'est ça s'il ya plusieurs types
de plastiques et au sort du même produit
et que ça le rend difficilement
recyclables il faudra garder déjà c'est
déjà les plastiques y sont simples on
arrive à tous les récupérer là j'ai pris
de celle montrée nous parce que leur
simple barquette
voilà vous m'avez dit en coulisse que
c'était dû piloter ce qui forme tout non
réduire le tsx le je vous laisse
quand même pu expliquer il est
brièvement pour le téléspectateur c'est
le sait un plastique qui compose toutes
les bouteilles d'eau oui c'est un
polyester en fait voilà on reconnaît
facilement sur les emballages parce
qu'il ya un petit un petit triangle
voilà avec un numéro
c'est vrai quand on connaît le numéro un
on sait que c'est du pt est là moi j'ai
du mal à coups de sabre
voilà faut le savoir mais encore une
fois faut aller chercher l'information
mais bon plex mais bon moi ce soit moins
compte moi honnêtement on est d'accord
qu'il ya un mois au relais mme
d'information de communication sur les
cours pourquoi cette barquette elle ne
va pas une liberté
heureusement qu'on a une scientifique là
pour nous confirmer encore vous êtes des
gens sachent ce que c'est que le pt
voilà mais en tout cas
naïvement bêtement je me suis dit ça
ressemble à du plastique transparent de
bouteilles et finalement j'avais pas
tort et je me dis pourquoi ça on le
recycle pas alors peut-être pour
répondre à la question en fait cette
barquette est un peu tes avant elle
était souvent dans une autre matière qui
posait un problème du recyclage avec les
bouteilles d'eau c'est pour ça qu'il a
été décidé que ça se soit pas
recyclables mais aujourd'hui je peux
vous dire que cette marque est sera
entièrement recyclée 1
maintenant le sujet d'une marque qui
sera nous fera quand ce sera fait de
vrais interdite si ce n'est pas
recyclable ce n'est pas possible heures
de deux médecins sur le marché public
parce que regarder après vous dites il
ya des tonnes de déchets on les met dans
les décharges on n'est pas capable de
les recycler et les industriels sont en
train de mettre sur le marché des
produits où on n'a pas encore la
technique de l'or du verdict les
mourides pour améliorer la recyclabilité
des emballages mondialement donc c'est
très important de pouvoir améliorer je
suis complètement d'accord il ya le
sujet de la russie qualité de
l'emballage
ensuite c'est le sujet du marquage des
emballages pour que nos consommateurs
une fois qu'il a fini de consommer et
puisse avoir une indication claire pour
pouvoir se dire bah tiens ça je le jette
près n'est pas encore recyclables même
si on y travaille
les sages leur cycle parce que ça sert
faut savoir une chose c'est que les
erreurs de tri
ça coûte 50 millions d'euros par an ça
veut dire que si on arrive à marquer
tous les emballages est ce ce que nous
évertuons à faire aujourd'hui il ya à
peu près 90 milliards d'emballages qui
sont produits chaque année
d'accord emballant les prix y en a à peu
près 40 qui sont marqués et on voit que
quand on marque les emballages et qu'on
aide le consommateur à au geste de tri
ça marche dix fois mais là encore une
fois alors une harmonisation c'est à
dire que voilà j'ai pris paraître deux
étiquettes de bouteilles plastiques
bouclard on sait que la bouteille
plastique avait recyclables voilà dans
une sur une étiquette on a écrit film
plastique a jeté mon et bouteilles
plastiques et son bouchon à recycler la
ja de l'aude informations parce que déjà
c'est clair mois déjà le film c'est le
film qui entoure la bouteille et au
léger donc vous vous imaginez vous avez
une étiquette mais quand vous avez
l'ensemble du packaging vous c'est clair
il ya un film qui entoure les une
bouteille même pas qu'il faut qu'il faut
détacher
pourtant évident dans l'app c'est notre
tâche et étiquettes ça c'est un geste
que non quand vous avez une bouteille
d'eau pourrait revenir avec le
spectateur
la bouteille entière vous ne l'enlevez
surtout pas les arcades ça sert à rien
vous prenez la bouteille entière vous
mettez le bouchon dessus vous le mettez
dans le bac de recyclage par contre le
film qui entoure les six bouteilles
voilà celui là vous le jetez oui il
n'est pas recyclable à date une et moi
ma bouteille je les achetais je
l'achetais individuellement mais les
rendez vous du coup d'ailleurs j'ai eu
un doute je me suis dit mais est ce que
c'est le film que qui est là sur ma
bouteille que j'ai acheté tout seul ou
est ce que c'est le plat d'électrodes
avaient carrément autour du pape aux
citoyens si il faut il faut dire
clairement aux gens c'est de l'éducation
man dès l'école à ce niveau là c'est
très compliqué chose des comptes vous un
film vous êtes hyper consciente et vie
n'a jamais douté ben oui
donc ça veut dire que la responsabilité
quand on prend un peu de recul
elle est surtout s'est produit parce que
regarder mon nom d'ahmad âge que ça crée
des emballages différents ceux qui sont
recyclables et ceux qui ne sont pas
après là dedans vous en avez qui le sont
et qui ne sont pas sur un même produit
dans m'attendais de qui le distingue en
garde michel évasive même si on est très
conscient ou est civique on veut faire
des colonies etc
c'est de ça qu'on est tombé c'est vrai
ça ça tue un peu la bonne volonté quand
on regarde votre documentaire on
comprend que le recyclage en france est
un vrai coup d'avancé alors que les
plastiques il ya ils connaissent trois
destins en gros la décharge
l'incinération ou le recyclage pourquoi
on à favoriser le recyclage en france -
que moins que d'autres solutions comme
l'incinération par exemple avait écouté
sur l'incinération
si on fait vous savez il ya à peu près
15 ans c'était tout incinération moi je
me suis bagarré contre les admirateurs
pourquoi parce que si on m'a choisi
c'est l'incinération et ben ont tué le
recyclage puisque il faut enfourner
enfourner enfourner donc on mettait du
papier mais on peut faire un essai 20
mai
il faut voir après quel est le
pourcentage de recyclage si vous veillez
à toujours les 3 r quand on veut être un
bon écolo il faut ré utiliser il faut
recycler il faut réduire on si vous
faites pas à l'étroit et si vous faites
que le recyclage et la réutilisation ça
marche pas c'est pour ça que je
n'assistais beaucoup sur la raison mais
et le recyclage c'est quand même là
petit on est dans l'économie circulaire
alors il faudrait que tous les produits
et c'est là où politiquement
moi je me bagarre sur le plan européen
on devait avoir une directive sur
l'économie circulaire elle a été rejetée
et peut-être alsa sera en 2016
mais c'est indispensable de dire aux
industriels parce que les industriels
ont une responsabilité que les
politiques de leur dire tous les
produits que vous allez mettre sur le
marché
il faut qu'il soit recyclable à 100% et
si c'est pas ça et que ce déchet ça va
après de matières premières parce que si
c'est pas ça on va crouler sur les
déchets mais quand vous voyez les
décharges et qu'en plus il ya un manque
de rompre en lan même sens et je vais
vous poser la question c'est ce qu'on
comprend aussi dans le documentaire il
ya une contradiction profonde entre la
motivation écologique du recyclage et
son fonctionnement économique parce que
pour fonctionner le recyclage il a
besoin de la production de plastique
donc si demain on réduit les productions
de plastique comment ça va vivre leur
cycle alors avoir la première chose
qu'il faut dire sur le recyclage c'est
qu'on peut pas d'un claquement de doigts
dire il ya qu'à faut qu'on est tous vers
bien ça c'est pas du tout ce que je dis
je vous pose une question si on suit la
logique que j'étais juste une question
c'est une logique si on dit on va
réduire les plastiques
si on réduit les choses forcément vous
allez plus alimenter ce qui fait
fonctionner une fille oui mais en fait
on sait que sur l'ensemble des
plastiques grosso modo il y en a 30 %
qui ne seront pas recycla pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui les à la protection des
produits toute une série de choses et de
contingence qui font que parce que ya
pas que le recycler le sujet recyclage
dans la consommation
il ya la protection des produits qui est
très importante parce que si on est à
l'ère du bio par exemple si on enlève
les conservateurs à l'intérieur faut
bien protéger le produit à l'extérieur
donc l'emballage devient absolument
stratégique pour protéger le
consommateur par ailleurs car son
utilisation
aussi la nouvelle manière de consommer
aujourd'hui quand on est une famille
avec plusieurs enfants et que les
enfants se sépare en ville etc
il faut bien un moment donné trouver un
emballage pour donner
quelque chose à manger on n'est pas le
plein
on a bien compris d'air dans le
documentaire qui a des plastiques utile
et c'est la question la question est de
savoir comment on va déterminer les
plastiques dont on ne peut pas se passer
et ce dont on peut se passer
alors justement on ne peut hélas hélas
je peux pas tolérer permet déjà posé la
question à scientifique et son athlète
hors la loi oui bah c'était pour vous
répondre
en fait peut-être un petit peu trop trop
dur de dire on va supprimer les
plastiques qui sont pas recyclables
ils sont pas recyclables aujourd'hui
d'accord là on n'a peut-être pas les
filières qui sont créées à azzan et
quand même qu'on se pose cette question
il a fait des années qu'on sait que les
sacs plastiques tu la biodiversité on
savait des années ont maintenant on a
une police sur les océans est incroyable
on découvre pas le problème maintenant
non et s'ils voulaient j'aimerais qu'on
anticipe pour une fois qu'on dise
et vous savez l'industriel s'il est sous
forme de contrats comprennent qu'on lui
dit vous avez 5 ans au bout de cinq ans
tout ce que vous allez produire doit
être recyclable à 100%
sinon ces interdictions et bien je vous
assure que ça développe la recherche
développement
ça développe les voix de recyclage eco
emballages
il peut se faire voyez à avoir une vraie
stratégie de récupération et tout le
monde est gagnant
alors qu'on joue entre mon nom c'est à
dire non et non il faudra que ça soit
recyclable c'est passionnant et hayes
alors et le recteur n'y a pas
d'interdiction tous ces trucs là qui se
recyclent pas et puis on fait plus on
fait complexe entre la bouteille qu'on
mais il faut enlever le bouchon et nous
allons remettre ça sert aussi que la
mairie langlois son côté valérie l'on
voit ça nous plaît on vous est faible
donc effectivement il ya plein
d'emballage qui ne sont pas qu'ils sont
qui sont pas encore aussi clamé c'est
vrai que la recherche a fait quand même
des des progrès depuis quelques années
alors c'est vrai que vous n'êtes on peut
parler on peut contester les plastiques
oxo dégradables en fait qui se fragmente
effectivement à l'oeil nu on ne voit
plus plastique mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'il a complètement disparu d'un autre
côté on évite un peu la macro pollution
la macro toxicité mêmes souliers ans non
mais moi j'aimerais bien qu'on aille
justement vers le totalement
biodégradable et la valorisation
organique valeur fils et ça et ça en
justement on y arrive parce que au
moment où l'allemagne et la suisse
valorise l
pour cent de leurs déchets la crée de
nouvelles filières et des emplois font
aussi des économies d'énergie nous on
est un peu à la traîne alors comment on
va pouvoir progresser on réécoute à un
extrait de documentaire mon emprunt la
question c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
déchets sont devenus une marchandise
on a fait une marchandisation des
déchets ce qui fait que le déchet est
devenu un produit monnayable
échangeables vendable achetable et il ya
une pression sur la production de ces
déchets que ce soit sur le recyclage
comme l'incinération et au stockage
on a des gens qui sont demandeurs de
déchets on ne peut pas leur en vouloir
c'est leur business
mais cette volonté de capter des flux de
déchets et d'avoir un train de déchets
constant de la même qualité en mêmes
proportions sur une année c'est
proprement incompatible avec les
velléités de réduction des déchets à la
source
on peut pas monétariser un léché et en
même temps dire qu'on va les médias
alors oui il est là juste vous avez
introduit en comparant avec l'allemagne
et la suisse alors ils valorisent
presque 100% de leurs déchets mais il ne
les recycle pas est bon c'est pour ça
que dire que la france est un mauvais
élève sans chauvinisme aucun voilà mais
il ya le recyclage et ensuite ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la valorisation
énergétique mais qui est de
l'incinération avec récupération
d'énergie parce qu'on ne brûle plus
comme avant oui dans le vent on brûle
quand même pour récupérer l'énergie du
chauffage s'est pas complètement les
meilleurs nutile j'ai donc donc voilà
donc finalement en termes de recyclage
pur donc c'est à dire je prends ma
matière je la réutilisent pour en
refaire une nouvelle matière en france
on n'est pas si à la traîne l'allemagne
la suisse et tout ça ils ont ils sont
pas au-dessus de 50%
bien en place et jusque ils ont
développé ils ont développé
l'incinération que nous voilà on cherche
aussi à faire il ya des usines en région
parisienne et paris ont demandé quel tas
mais il a été tout à fait intéressant
c'est que les pays européens ont
tendance à récupérer les déchets aller
collecter ensuite à les envoyer en asie
en inde ou en chine la france la moitié
des déchets plastiques collectés
non-lieu partent en chine pour y être
retraité sa cellule
en france on recycle 93 % des déchets
sur le sol national
il ya plus de trente recycleurs et donc
à l'époque les élus quand ils ont créé
en fait cette filière là ont eu
conscience non seulement de développer
le recyclage parce que c'est essentiel
et 3 1 % des déchets au global 93% des
déchets d'emballages ménagers à ceux qui
sont gérés par eco emballages sont
recyclés sur le sol national qui a créé
28 mille emplois c'est quand même pas
rien on en récupère même de chez nos
voisins les allemands emploient des
pratiques en france est sixième le
technology est plutôt très bien très
bonne et d'une certaine manière ça se
développe moi je pense qu'on peut pas
gérer ce sujet là que en regardant à un
point spécifique
la première fonction en fait sur ce
sujet là c'est la prévention c'est à
dire la réduction du poids des dézonage
une bouteille d'eau a été réduit de 25 %
en dix ans est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
quand vous prenez une bouteille d'eau
parfois quand quand vous la prenez elle
se tord un petit peu ce qu'elle est
tellement allégé et donc les emballages
ont assez bien progressé au niveau de
l'allègement là où il faut que ça ça
progresser l'intégration de recycler à
mon avis dans les emballages et le
développement de la réfutabilité ça
c'est vrai c'est un sujet de recherche
c'est aussi un sujet de conscience
globale parce que c'est parce qu'il y
aura des demandeurs de ces matières
recyclées que ça créera une intention de
davantage recyclé ouest en suède en
suède ils rachètent leur filière de
recyclage est tellement tellement
innovantes et marchent très bien qu'il
se retrouve c'est ce qui est l'extrait
qu'on a vu c'est qu'à un moment ils
n'ont plus assez de plastique pour faire
tourner leurs usines
parce qu'ils ont développé toute une
industrie et du coup ils achètent ou aux
pays de l'est ou en tout cas ils
récupèrent pour pouvoir avoir la matière
et donc on est dans cette province est
alimentée draps non selon la radio
voilà alors et je voulais juste des
petites questions simples que les gens
se posent
on aurait tendance à dire bah tiens les
bouteilles en plastique on peut
remplacer par du verre est ce que le
verre c'est vraiment plus écolo est ce
que ça est ce que ça coûte plus cher
moins cher ou est ce que le verre c'est
à dire les plastiques végétaux pas ici
dans le vert éleveurs
les revers il faut réduire les
plastiques le vert est une alternative à
balad c'est à dire pour le maire aussi
que la dent se recycle mais il faut
chauffer beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup
plus d'énergie pour recycler du verre
que pour recycler les matières
plastiques sur facebook et puis pour les
transports réseaux respectivement les
biberons en plastique c'est plus léger
fal et bouteilles je voulais pas mais
quand même il faut regarder tout le
cycle si je peux me permettre
oui parce que on parle du plastique mais
il faut parler santé visées du plastique
comment parler de lui bron je pense de
suite au bisphénol à un puisque on a
fait des biberons en plastique les
températures des tornado craignant qu
est un perturbateur et que ça passait
dans l'est après on avait des phtalates
donc ça veut dire que vous voyez il faut
tout regarder
il faut regarder le poids comme vous
dites mais ça suffit pas il faut pas
qu'ils les molécules chimiques ou en
fonction de la chaleur ça passe dans les
aliments et on a une grosse polémique en
ce moment sur le plan européen
après sur le vert si on mettrait
citoyens on le voit d'ailleurs chez les
allemands d'autres pays
il ya les consignes avant il y avait
bien les consignes sur le lait ou sur
d'autres produits pourquoi pas revenir
aussi à ça parce que le plastique
attention ces faits à base de pétrole
alors maintenant il ya de la chimie
verte on va en discuter
enfin rien d'apparent de la consommation
mondiale de pétrole est absorbée par la
fabrication des matières plastiques
voilà et si on dit avec la cap 21 en
décembre si on veut être exemplaire sur
les gaz à effet de serre il va falloir
lisser 80% des énergies fossiles dans le
sol donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
sorte de l'addiction au pétrole
si on veut sortir de l'addiction au
pétrole il va falloir supprimer
énormément de choses en plastique mais
alors là le quai est pas rentré dans le
cadre de ce que vous dites sur la suède
où il se dit ah ben on a means il ya en
place une fois énormément plastique
parce que là on est encore dans la
société jetables là où justement il faut
pas non plus je trouve trop taper sur
place et qui nous sert en allemagne ils
ont fait un autre choix il ya quinze ans
c'est
le plastiki serez utilise donc leurs
bouteilles elles sont plus épaisses donc
ils les lave
c'est vrai qu'il ya un moment il faut se
dire voilà qu'on soit là il ya 20 ans
nous si l'allemagne parce que là on la
détruit et on arrive à l'époque à 20 ans
je sais pas là-bas en fait quand vous
regardez les rapports de l'ademe et les
étude de l'ademe qui sont très précises
elles montrent que le type de
consommation en allemagne est
généralement une consommation beaucoup
plus local c'est à dire que les sources
et notamment sont dans un périmètre
d'environ 100 km et la consigne ça
marche quand on produit qu'on consomme
et qu'on récupère la matière dans un
rayon à peu près de 100 clients à partir
du moment dépasse 200 km on s'aperçoit
que l'effet co2 comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure sur sur le transport et
ses nappes ne donne pas un bilan
environnemental satisfaisant ces deux
modèles radicalement différent
aujourd'hui mettre en place une consigne
faut savoir une chose c'est que tout
ceci est quand même payé par le
consommateur
donc en fait qu on fait l'addition des
coûts et moi je vérifie ça vient parce
que faire de l'écologie c'est formidable
il faut aussi faire de l'écologie avec
une certaine sobriété économique sinon
met en place des systèmes qui au final
sont payés par le consommateur et qui
finalement n'ont pas d'impact
environnemental donc pas entre nous et
donc est donc interdite sur la faune la
vie d'hier de la réutilisation affirmé
sur la cuisse du championnat c'est
intéressant en fait d'étudier notamment
quand il ya des bassins de population
qu'ils sont petits ce genre de système
par contre globalement on s'aperçoit que
l'utilisation des plastiques et la
réutilisation des plastiques est passé
mais tellement meilleur en allemagne
qu'en france
et ça je pourrais en parler alors on a
vu un dans le documentaire que il existe
les bioplastiques c'est le plastiques
végétaux
ça c'est votre domaine valérie langlois
on comprend que sur ce sujet là il ya
des bas aussi il ya eu des abus mais en
fait le problème c'est ce qu'on a dit
c'est la fin de vie du plastique
biodégradable qui pose question en
particulier en milieu marin puisque
quand ils s'auto détruit il se fragmente
et donc c'est encore plus difficile à
éradiquer
c'est au alors aujourd'hui où on en est
vous je sais que vous êtes en train de
déposer un brevet avec un industriel
mais c'est encore assez secret d'abord
expliquez-nous ce que c'est que cette
matière naturelle
sa durée de vie et puis voilà qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui nous attend là je crois
qu'il faut pas qu'ils étaient confuses
sûrs entre matière plastique
oxodégradable donc en fait effectivement
il va rester des petits fragments de
matières plastiques qui seront nocives
et le totalement biodégradable bio une
matière plastique biodégradable ça veut
dire qu'elle est assimilable par des
micro-organismes et qu'à la fin il ne
reste plus que du co2 de l'eau ou de
l'humus ou de la biomasse
donc il ya plus du tout du tout le
magret ça c'est rien il reste plus rien
la bactérie ou les champignons ou enfin
microorganismes sont capables d'ingérer
ces matières là et il ne reste
absolument plus matières plastiques on
en a juste donné un exemple pour vous
c'est peut-être un petit peu abstrait
pour vous mais c'était s'est beaucoup
développée dans le domaine biomédical
haut niveau par exemple des fils de
suture à lorsque vous avez une opération
vourc'h ou soissons défilent non
dégradables non résorbables qui font
enlever
soit ce sont des fils qui vont
totalement disparaître et vous si vous
avez déjà été recousu voyez bien qu'il
ya aucune toxicité pour l'être vivant
enfin pour nous mêmes et donc ils
disparaissent totalement donc c'est un
peu le même concept là ce sont des
polymères qui existent on peut mettre
ensuite dans la nature ils sont
totalement bio 6000 il s'agit pas non
plus de jeter ça n'importe où ni en mai
alors c'est parce que c'est à dire ce
qu'on voit à quel point c'est complexe
il faut combien de temps par exemple
pour vous les produits sur lesquels vous
travaillez les matières sur lesquelles
vous travaillez s'autodétruisent il faut
combien de mois on pour une matière
biodégradable on lui demande de
disparaître en six mois et dans le
milieu marin alors ça dépend du milieu
marin si vous allez dans les mers
froides ou des mers chaudes mais c'est
pareil le biodégradable ces six mois
c'est peut-être un peu plus long dans le
milieu marin puisque s'est diluée par
rapport à un compost donc par de quoi
les mâles dégradables alors il ya deux
types de biodégradables soit du
biodégradable fait à partir de 2
de la biomasse donc d'espèces végétales
voilà de maïs ou de plantes
voilà beaucoup de l'amidon ou alors ça
peut être également fait à partir de
dérivés du pétrole
alors mais quand c'est fait à partir de
moi je citerai le poly acide lactique
qui est fait à partir de l'acide
lactique dérivés de l'amidon c'est une
matière qui est totalement biodégradable
et qui est déjà utilisée je sais pas si
vous mangez certainement de la glace
vous allez manger cet été peut-être donc
soit vous prenez un corner en glace soit
un petit pot vous mettez votre glace
dedans une fois que vous mangez pas le
pot de glace
une fois que vous l'avez utilisé c'est
vrai que quand on sais pas en quoi c'est
fait en général on met dans la poubelle
alors c'est dommage parce que certains
pots sont faits en polymère
biodégradable et pour être complètement
assimilé par les micro-organismes voilà
donc c'est aussi un problème peut-être
de communication c'est à dire qu'on a
faim les industriels qui développent ce
type de produits ne paient pas assez
fait d'informations pas assez avery
public et il faudrait valeureux
développer cette filière de valorisation
organique d'ailleurs à ce sujet moi il
ya quelque chose d'aussi que j'ai
remarqué dans mon documentaire c'est
l'information sur ce plastique recyclé
on le recycle
mais on en fait quoi en fait on n'est
jamais informé que par exemple nos
bouteilles voilà sur les filiales et en
même d'aider un fish longtemps c'était à
partir de temps de bouteilles en
plastique on faisait beaucoup de kull
polaire oui bien sûr voilà deux ans
quand on va acheté par deux mois je vais
acheter ma bouteille en classique
je ne sais pas si elle est faite avec du
plastique recyclé nous allons il indiqué
c'est indiqué sur les certaines
bouteilles quand ils utilisent ils le
mais il met une certaine proportion de
place de plastinats moi je vais regarder
alors je sais que j'ai une question ou
telle marque mais on voit et on voit ce
sixième continent leur et qui dérivent
voilà chaque année les sacs plastiques
tueur et un million d'oiseaux 100000
tortues marines est catastrophique
la biodégradation en milieu marin est
plus compliqué vraisemblablement
aujourd'hui on a des est-ce qu'on a des
idées ou des bribes de solutions pour ce
qui est en train de dériver dans les
océans et de tuer la faune marine
ou est-ce que
voilà c'est maintenant je pense que les
plastiques réellement biodégradables se
dégrade en six mois voire un an est
aujourd'hui dans les maisons là je
voudrais maintenant il va rester des
micros des micros son appel des micro
plastiques en fait est qu'ils sont
toxiques
mais il n'ya pas que dans la mer ce dans
tous les milieux aquatiques en fait un x
les gens les micro plastiques en fait ne
deviennent invisibles
oui oui c'est donc vous les retrouvez en
fait sans le savoir vous en mangez dans
les coquillages voilà j'en fais dans
l'organisme ce qu'on peut dire là dessus
c'est qu'elle ait récupéré ces
plastiques qui ruisselle dans la mer est
d'ailleurs des plastiques que vous
trouvez dans la mer ne sont pas jetés
sur la côte et ruisselle de très loin
ils mettent des années à risque et il
arrive dans la mer très à très très
atomisé donc on peut plus les ramasser
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'il
faut absolument arrêter le meilleur -
moyen de régler le problème de la mer
c'est de créer une barrière à la
pollution juste après la consommation
c'est le geste de tri c'est par le geste
de tri qu'on arrivera à avoir moins de
plastique dans la mer on ne peut pas
raconter aux gens qu'on va aller pêcher
les emballages maintenant qu'on peut
diriger de poisson parce que c'est
toujours la veille c'est au
fonctionnariat toujours mon avis a
toujours refusé à la collecte la
collecte je pense oui mes sujets qui
nous unit mais c'est la collecte les -
aussi - one plastique c'est moi une
plastie il faut que le plastique soit
réservé à des choses vraiment haut de
gamme quoi te bannir la voiture par
exemple moyen de faire autrement
mais il faut quand même dire au
consommateur qu'on est on va faire ses
courses il faut avoir un sac en toile
est littéralement le fait l'europe là
dessus lorsqu'on a pris cette directive
au début on avait tous les lobbys qui
étaient contre nous puisqu'on avait
aussi le lobby pour les sacs à
fragmentation et les oxydes auxi se
dégrade à bhl mais de dire aux gens il
faut arrêter dans notre cette
consommation cette fuite en avant parce
que vous vous êtes industriels plus à la
limite il ya des choses qu'on peut
recycler meilleur c'est non nous venons
mais les industriels souhaitent réduire
le poids des emballages et souhaite
faire en sorte que ça soit le plus
recyclé possible c'est fini le temps où
les années série elle le souhaitait pas
recyclés madame oui je vois tout s'est
emballé à jour les industriels et six
mois puis soirée en allemand
de meilleure vie à des grandes surfaces
qui disent eh bien on arrête et
emballages ont réduit au maximum les
grandes surfaces le dise en face à
quitter le grand nombre d'industriels
qui disent qu'il souhaite d'une part
arrêté les emballages non recyclables
etc
ça se fait je peux dire qu'on a changé
nous sommes en train parce qu'il faut
pas voir que les on est souvent en train
stigmatiser ce qui va pas etc
mais je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui toute l'europe regarde
l'expérimentation qu'on fait sur le
recyclage de tous les plastiques toute
l'europe
nous allons doubler le taux de recyclage
en moins de 15 ans passés de 23 56 % qui
sera à peu près au niveau de du duc de
la volonté de laurence et si je peux
vous dire que ça en 15 ans comment les
biens sont à mon avis il faudra entre
eux oui pas loin de dix ans pourquoi
et oui parce que c'est tout à l'heure je
le disais mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
très populaire ça ne se fait pas d'un
claquement de doigts il faut unir des
jurés aient fait venir des cultures et
des acteurs qui ce qu'ils se parlent pas
moi je peux vous dire que je rassemble
des acteurs explique 4000 personnes qui
sont venues à nos réunions pour le
recyclage des plastiques des
associations des industriels des
opérateurs donné chez des élus mais c
était un grand succès c'est vrai qu'on
va bien je suis désolé on arrive à faire
du débat comme quoi ya encore beaucoup à
dire merci beaucoup à tous devenus sur
son plateau la semaine prochaine laurent
bazin vous proposera un documentaire sur
jean marie le pen et moi dans 15 jours
je vous emmène rencontrer des
apiculteurs en banlieue parisienne
à très vite sur queen's